à tout et maintenant regardez regardez
bien ce disque se disent que c'est en
principe le disque de l'avenir un disque
numérique
inusable ou presque hinault rentrer en
contact avec aucun objet puisque c'est
un rayon laser qui le sillonnent il faut
pour cela un appareil adéquate en vente
depuis hier dans les magasins de ici
alors patrick esther vous dit tout sur
le disque numérique
cette fois pour entrer dans notre cadre
de vie familiale le microprocesseur
cette puce savante inventé par
l'électronique du 20e siècle a choisi
une voie originale la musique
cet appareil est l'un des tout premier
lecteur laser de disques numériques
l'apparition de ce matériel représente
un bouleversement profond dans le monde
de la musique et de la haute fidélité
plus que cela encore
c'est le symbole d'une nouvelle forme
d'industrie celle des technologies de
pointes appliqués aux loisirs
ce petit disque de 12 cm de diamètre
seulement permet l'enregistrement d'une
heure de musique d'où son nom de
compacts disques à côté de lui
le traditionnel 33 tours fait déjà
figure d'ancêtre avec la journaliste
classique une pointe frob dans le sillon
du disque et se met à vibrer en montant
et en descendant le long des boss du
sillon avec le compact disc le sillon
disparaît remplacé par des milliards de
minuscules trous percés suivant un code
numérique que seul
l'ordinateur peut analyser bien sûr ces
trous sont si petits qu'une aiguille ne
peut plus les lire n'utilise le faisceau
de lumière d'un laser
cette combinaison ordinateur laser
permet toutes sortes d'amélioration il
est par exemple possible de programmer
l'ordre dans lequel on désire écouter
les différentes chansons d'un disque
mais surtout cette combinaison lazer
ordinateur permet d'obtenir un relief
sonore digne des meilleures
installations professionnelles sans
aucun souffle et sans bruit de fond si
vous décidez de vous équiper
pas besoin de tout changer ses lecteurs
se branchent sur n'importe quelle chaîne
hi fi
une seule ombre au tableau le prix des
appareils de 6000 à 8000 francs un prix
très élevé qui semble-t-il ne devrait
pourtant pas empêcher l'explosion du
marché de ce nouveau système
nous pensons que le 33 tours
traditionnel disparaîtra dans une
dizaine d'années
c'est donc une révolution relativement
rapide quant aux prix actuels
bien entendu c'est un prix élevé mais ce
prix élevé nous avez enclin à une
certaine prudence
or l'exemple du japon montre que ce prix
élevé est tout à fait accepté par le
public l'avantagent produits étant
tellement décisif que le public estime
que le rapport qualité prix est quand
même très très favorable et le japon
vingt mille machines mis sur le marché
au mois d'octobre
toutes ces machines ont disparu en
quelques jours c'est vous dire si
l'accueil du public a été très favorable
par comment ça se passe et pour les gens
qui veulent une grosse discothèque de 33
tours
les éditeurs transféreront sur le
compact disc les anciens documents
sonores dont ils peuvent disposer par
conséquent on peut penser que la plupart
des mélomanes remplaceront
progressivement dans les années qui
viennent leur ancienne discothèque qui
était sous forme de micro sim
traditionnelle par du compact disc au
rythme de l'usure de leurs micro sillon
on fabrique ce disque exactement comme
des satellites ou des microprocesseurs
dans de vastes usines entièrement
blanche
habillés de combinaisons de vinyle
l'ennemi numéro un
la poussière ici on travaille au micron
près une seule poussière sur le moule et
ce sont des centaines de disques perdu
30% de ceux qui sortent de cette presse
partent pour la poubelle
et lorsque cette usine a démarré la
chaîne il y a quelques mois plus de la
moitié étaient inutilisables
c'est dire à quel point la production de
ces disques est une affaire délicate
paradoxe du progrès technique plus
l'objet à fabriquer petit plus il faut
une usine complexe est gigantesque
à ce jour trois usines seulement au
monde sont capables de produire ses
compacts disques la première en
allemagne un an
sur ces images la seconde au japon la
troisième aux etats-unis est en cours
d'implantation
al'inverse du magnétoscope le standard
du compact disc est international
standard unique qui amène aujourd'hui un
redéploiement mondial de l'industrie du
disque
cette usine des compacts disques a coûté
environ 90 millions de francs
naturellement c'est une somme que les
petites compagnies de disques ne peuvent
plus investir
seules les grosses compagnies peuvent se
le permettre et nous déjà nous sommes
prêts à nous à grandir et à passer à la
phase 2 c'est à dire investir encore 45
millions
cette nouvelle technologie risque donc à
terme de faire disparaître les petites
sociétés au profit de groupes très
puissants
la révolution technique du compact disc
n'est pas sans effet sur le plan social
les machines coûte tellement cher que
pour les amortir même cette usine qui ne
travaillait jusqu'ici avec deux équipes
vient d'instaurer les trois huit
une fois finie ce disque si délicat à
réaliser devient inusable inrayable la
musique qu'au départ l'ordinateur défie
le temps de nombreux chefs d'orchestre
contemporains ont compris la chance que
représente pour eux cette technique
herbert von karajan enregistre déjà
depuis plusieurs années en numérique
ainsi l'ordinateur permet aux
interprètes de devenir les égaux des
sculpteurs ou des peintres leurs oeuvres
pouvant enfin survivre à la mort et
c'est peut-être la plus belle
contribution du compact disc évacuation
ce matin d'amy